all right the nba finals are here and
they're in a bubble
here to explain that and so much more is
sports journalist
jamelle hill and the host of the
incredible interview podcast jemele hill
is unbothered
jamal i mean everybody
you know you're you're so major thank
you for coming to our show
well thank you for having me that means
so much coming from you yeah i was like
freaking out when i found out you were
coming here so
thank you and we're big sports fans here
and you know our friend christy uh who's
my social media partner in crime she
says when they're sports there's hope
and i
i so agree with that sentiment and um so
we want to get into
sports news with you i mean
hello thank you this is certainly a way
to kick off sports okay first up serena
williams
pulled out of the french open over an
injured achilles tendon
heartbreaking news for her fans can you
give us some context on this
yeah it is heartbreaking because i think
uh so many of
serena's fans myself included just not
only being a fan of hers but just being
uh someone who is in charge of
chronicling sports history
we want to see her break this record the
record that's held by margaret court
for having the most grand slam titles
ever ever she's one away from tying
and so with every competition that she's
in every slam
we're just waiting with baited breath to
see like is this the one
will she do it and look serena doesn't
have anything else in her career to
prove
but i think this record is important for
me regardless if she gets this record or
not
i still think she's the greatest female
tennis player ever one of the greatest
athletes period
man or woman to ever have played sports
i think that we're so
um involved in her life and as a woman
wife mother you know the greatest
athlete
uh businesswoman i think we're invested
in this
amazing marker of hers and we're all
waiting like this but it's like
her you say her name and you know
all eyes and ears are open as well as
hearts okay the nba finals are in full
swing
and all eyes are on the bubble and the
teams have been playing and
what do you think how did it work out i
think the bubble has been
a resounding success like a lot of
people i certainly have my doubts but
the nba has been a real leader
in terms of showing a blueprint to how
we can still enjoy sports professional
sports
um and even being among this pandemic i
think it's provided a lot of light you
said this at the beginning of this
segment is that sports does give us hope
and the mba with how responsible they've
been
with how ahead of the curve they've been
with the virus testing
and even even helping in terms of the
rest of the society
figure out a way that we can have
accurate concise
testing on a regular basis that can help
us live some kind of normalcy
they've been great at this but
nevertheless you know for a lot of
people
uh just the sports aspect of this to see
the lakers in this position
i think it means a lot to folks i know
it feels like it happened a long time
ago because of everything we've
experienced
but kobe bryant died earlier this year
and that was a devastating loss
in all of sports and so for the lakers
to be in this position to be
able to win a title to honor his memory
i think is very
important and special not just to lakers
fans but to all nba fans all sports fans
period well i was gonna say what is your
prediction the heat or the lakers so
i think i know where your heart is at
but do you have a prediction
i do uh look the lakers are going to
cakewalk to this title this was not an
easy experience
to be in the bubble but they by far have
the best team in the nba lebron james
um you know he's one of the biggest
stars in the world
he will have completed his mission there
you go
fall out drew because it's true lebron
is going to bring
another title to the los angeles lakers
and i'm sure for a lot of people here in
la where i live like this is
uh really for them they feel like this
is their birthright that the lakers
were here to win titles and so for him
to deliver on this
after coming to this team i think it's
going to mean a lot
uh to his fans and to everybody in this
city an incredible thing to come
together on
at this time thank you jamelle so
much jamelle's show stick to sports
there's one day wednesday nights on vice
one of my favorite channels
you